the chevy colorado has been flying off a
lot since it hit dealerships in october
colorado is what's called a midsize
truck my definition that's a vehicle
that can carry less than 1500 pounds and
the designation matters because Detroit
hasn't made midsize trucks in years the
fear was a smaller truck would lure
buyers away from more lucrative
full-size models Chevy saw an
opportunity with this truck if thought
it could bring in a whole new class of
buyers people who had always wanted to
pick up but couldn't justify buying a
full-size model basically city dwellers
trying to squeeze into an awful tight
spot
this truck is so massive I'd be lost
without the rear bumper camera here's
the thing though the Colorado isn't
really midsize at all it's actually kind
of big in terms of height weight and
width is roughly the same size as
Chevy's full-size truck from over a
decade ago so what gives
first of all trucks in general have been
super-sized in the past two decades
Chevy Silverado has grown by almost a
foot in length four inches in height and
it's put on almost 700 pounds all that
bulk means the truck can tow heavier
loads and perform better and crash tests
two things the truck buyers really care
about secondly Chevy is hoping the
Colorado can be all things to all people
not just a tool for tradesman that's why
every one of them comes with four doors
a feature that actually makes it longer
than GM's full-size sibling
Chevy's done a great job marketing this
as a small urban vehicle it's selling
almost 7,000 on a month that's a tally
higher than the suburban which is giant
SUV but drivers shouldn't kid themselves
trucks in the u.s. these days come in
two sizes large and larger midsize is
for the marketing team